(“Parece que sí)
(“Buenas noches a los argentinos de bien
porque hoy comienza la reconstrucción de
la Argentina)
Y se hizo la luz. Queridos amigos, amigas,
la tormenta electoral argentina ha terminado.
¿Y sabéis qué? La comunidad de VisualPolitik
estaba en lo cierto. Las casi 140 mil personas
que respondisteis a nuestra pregunta electoral
lo clavásteis.
Milei será el nuevo presidente de la República
Argentina. Y no lo será por un margen precisamente
pequeño. En la segunda vuelta el león liberal
ha reventado todos los pronósticos y se ha
hecho con casi el 56% de los votos. Le ha
sacado 11 puntos al candidato peronista Sergio
Massa.
En estas elecciones el peronismo ha tenido
uno de los peores resultados de toda su historia,
al tiempo que Milei se ha convertido en el
presidente con más porcentaje de apoyo electoral
desde el regreso de la democracia en 1983.
Hoy la mayoría de los argentinos celebran
una victoria que traerá consigo un histórico
cambio de gobierno. Ahora sí que sí, de
una forma u otra, la Argentina se lanzará
por el tobogán del cambio. La promesa de
Milei es dar la vuelta como un calcetín al
modelo económico y social del país gaucho.
(“Quiero decirles a todos los argentinos
que hoy comienza el fin de la decadencia argentina.
Hoy empezamos a dar vuelta a la página de
nuestra historia y volvemos a retomar el camino
que nunca deberíamos haber perdido, hoy se
termina el modelo empobrecedor
del Estado omnipresente que solo beneficia
a algunos mientras la mayoría de los
argentinos sufren”)
Sin embargo, queridos amigos, y sin querer
aguaros la fiesta, especialmente a quienes
nos veis desde el país del asado, el tango
y el futbol, el entusiasmo por la victoria
puede durar poco. Ahora toca hacer lo más
difícil: enfrentarse a todos los problemas
que arrastra consignó la economía de este
país.
Porque, seamos claros, Argentina no necesita
cambios cosméticos o pequeños retoques.
Para nada. La Argentina necesita llevar a
cabo urgentemente un montón de reformas que
afecten a prácticamente todos los campos
económicos y sociales: gasto público, legislación
laboral, regulaciones, apertura al exterior…
y un largo, larguísimo etcétera de materias
absolutamente imprescindibles.
(“Que se entienda bien, la situación de
Argentina es crítica. Los cambios que nuestro
país necesita son drásticos, no hay lugar
para gradualismo, no hay lugar para la tibieza,
no hay lugar para medias tintas.)
Pues bien, estos que vamos a ver a continuación
son algunos de los grandes retos con los que
ahora Javier Milei se tendrá que ver las
caras. Pero, amigos, amigas, si os parece,
empecemos la historia por el principio.
¡Arranquemos!
(“Viva la libertad, Carajo”.
“Viva la libertad, Carajo”.
Dios bendiga a los argentinos
Muchas gracias)
Buenos Aíres, la capital de la Argentina,
es habitualmente descrita como la capital
de un imperio que nunca existió. Y no es
para menos, esta hermosa ciudad es el vivo
reflejo de un vibrante pasado que hoy deviene
en una frustrante nostalgia.
Creo que ya todos lo sabéis, hacia finales
del siglo XIX y principios del siglo XX, el
país gaucho era una tierra próspera y pujante
que se codeaba de tú a tú con las principales
potencias del mundo, incluyendo a los mismísimos
Estados Unidos.
Podemos decir que por aquella época, Argentina
tenía su propia visión del sueño americano
y por aquella época los argentinos acariciaban
el cielo.
Pero amigos, amigas, durante el resto del
siglo XX del cielo se pasó al infierno. Argentina
dejó de ser una de las economías más vibrantes
del mundo para convertirse en una de las más
decadentes de todo el planeta. Año tras año
el país no deja de perder puestos en el ranking
mundial.
Argentina es uno de los pocos países del
mundo que está en vías no al desarrollo,
sino al subdesarrollo. Al menos en términos
relativos.
(“Cuando la Argentina entró en el siglo
XX, era el país más rico del mundo. Argentina
tenía una de las monedas más sólidas del
mundo. Millones de inmigrantes se agolpaban
ante nuestras costas para poder tener la chanza
de tener un futuro mejor. Éramos la envidia
del mundo. Sin embargo, en un momento la clase
política decidió que la riqueza de los argentinos
no podía estar en manos de los argentinos,
sino que tenía que estar en las manos de
ellos.”)
Pero de todo eso ya os hemos hablado un montón
de veces aquí en VisualPolitik, así que
hoy con este vídeo nuestra intención es
completamente distinta.
Queridos amigos, amigas, tras un siglo XX
repleto de golpes de Estado y gobiernos autoritarios,
el día 10 de diciembre de 2023 se conmemora
el 40 aniversario de la reinstauración democrática.
Ese mismo día Javier Milei será investido
presidente con unas promesas de cambio tan
grandes como los titánicos problemas que
padece Argentina. Un país en el que por ahora
la prosperidad parece una meta inalcanzable.
(“Quiero ser muy claro con algo: el modelo
de la decadencia ha llegado a su fin no hay
vuelta atrás”)
Aquí en VisualPolitik y también en VisualEconomik
ya os hemos hablado de muchas de las promesas
de Milei. Pero ahora, con la aplastante victoria
del candidato libertario, han surgido más
preguntas:
¿Cuáles son los principales obstáculos
a los que se enfrentará la Argentina para
poder volver a brillar? ¿Qué cosas tienen
que arreglar los argentinos para poder salir
adelante? Y visto, lo visto, ¿Con qué problemas
tendrá que lidiar Milei si finalmente llega
a convertirse en el nuevo presidente de la
Argentina?
Pues bien, sin más preámbulo, busquemos
ya las respuestas a todas estas preguntas.
Óscar todo tuyo.
(UNA GENERACIÓN ACORRALADA)
Lo primero que tenemos que tener en cuenta
para valorar el potenciar de Argentina es
que estamos hablando de un país de 45 millones
de habitantes que, a diferencia, de la mayor
parte de países occidentales sigue siendo
razonablemente joven.
De hecho, según estimaciones de Naciones
Unidas, durante la próxima década la población
joven de Argentina será la mayor de toda
su historia.
Envídenteme, esto supone, una gran ventaja.
Pero, claro, no basta con tener una población
joven. La clave está en sí un país es o
no capaz de aprovechar ese potencial, si realmente
tiene capacidad para explotar todo ese talento
potencial… Y justo aquí es donde las cosas
dejan de pintar tan bien.
De entrada, si bien la pobreza del país ronda
el 40% en los últimos 5 años, esta se acentúa
claramente entre los más jóvenes. Según
los datos oficiales, más del 54% de todos
los niños y adolescentes argentinos viven
en condiciones de pobreza… Con todo lo que
ello conlleva.
Por ejemplo, el Observatorio “Argentinos
por la Educación”, ha realizado un seguimiento
detallado de las últimas promociones de estudiantes
tituladas, tanto a nivel de educación primaria
como de secundaria. Y, ¿Sabéis qué? Los
resultados son alarmantes.
Por ejemplo, en el 2016 cerca de 750.000 niños
argentinos comenzaron la educación primaria,
y aunque el 92% llegó a terminarla en tiempo
y forma, solo el 43% de todos estos estudiantes
pasó a la educación secundaria con conocimientos
mínimos aceptables tanto en lengua como en
matemáticas.
Y, claro, este proceso termina actuando en
cadena: los estudiantes que terminar la primaria,
sin conocimientos básicos, repiten el mismo
patrón en la secundaria, un nivel educativo
dónde el panorama argentino resulta simple
y llanamente desolador.
Atentos a este dato: solo 13 de cada 100 estudiantes
que ingresan en la educación secundaria la
terminan en el tiempo teórico estipulado
y con los conocimientos mínimos aceptables
en lengua y matemáticas. Solo 13 de cada
100. Es un desastre gigantesco que muchos
expertos argentinos están definiendo ya como
una “tragedia educativa” sin precedentes.
N1(17 de abril de 2023: 7 de cada 10 argentinos
creen que la educación está peor que 30
años atrás y que caerá aún más. InfoBae)
N2(4 de mayo de 2023: Alerta por un informe
sobre educación en Argentina: "Esto es una
tragedia silenciosa. CNN)
Atentos a lo que decía este editorial del
diario la Nación del 28 de junio de 2023:
N3(Educación: una emergencia impostergable.
Reconocer la emergencia del sistema educativo
nacional en todos los niveles y modalidades
es el primer paso. La Nación)
El problema es que los cambios educativos
son terriblemente lentos. Incluso aunque de
repente consigas reformar todo el modelo de
arriba abajo, los resultados tardaran un montón
años en llegar. Y por el camino, además,
es probable que se quede pérdida toda una
generación.
Y eso si consigues sacar adelante un cambio
integral… Porque si no… Pinta mal. Los
resultados educativos de Argentina van de
mal en peor. Fijaos.
En pantalla podéis ver como en las evaluaciones
realizadas por la UNESCO sobre capacidad de
comprensión lectora, Argentina es el segundo
país con peor evolución. Solo la supera
en evolución negativa Guatemala. Mientras
tanto, otros países como Perú, Brasil o
Paraguay lograron importantes avances.
Y eso que hablamos de 2019. Todo apunta a
que con el terrible desempeño de Argentina
durante la pandemia de la Covid-19 hoy las
cosas son aún peor, mucho peor.
Así que ya lo veis, las nuevas generaciones
parecen acorraladas: por un lado, sufren un
sistema educativo que cada vez es peor, viven
mayoritariamente con unas condiciones muy
precarias - la pobreza infantil y juvenil
no deja de crecer - y luego, para colmo, a
medida que van cerrando su etapa académica,
se dan de bruces con una economía que también
va de mal en peor.
¿Y qué queréis qué os diga? En cierto
modo, es muy probable que esto sea lo que
explique por qué los jóvenes se han echado
masivamente en brazos de la apuesta rupturista
de Javier Milei.
Por supuesto, todo esto que os estamos contando
tiene importantes implicaciones, no solo sociales
y políticas, sino también económicas. Una
escasa y pobre formación equivale a mucha
menos productividad… En un momento en el
que Argentina lo que necesita es, precisamente,
mejorar mucho este parámetro.
Pero ya veis que en lugar de eso, lo que vemos
es una especie de espiral destructiva.
Punto importante en cualquier receta de soluciones.
En cualquier caso quedémonos con la mejor
cara: Argentina tendrá un aluvión de jóvenes
disponibles para poner en marcha de nuevo
su motor económico. Simplemente, hay que
conseguir que todos esos jóvenes, de una
forma u otra, puedan ponerse manos a la obra.
Dicho esto, pasemos a otro gran problema muy
relacionado, además, con este que hemos visto:
¿Está la industria argentina preparada para
competir? ¿Hasta qué punto puede la actual
matriz productiva liderar el cambio?
Atentos.
(LOS REHENES DE LA INDUSTRIA)
Queridos amigos, amigas, aquí en VisualPolitik
ya hemos visto en pasados vídeos la particular
relación - o mejor dicho, fobia - que el
peronismo mantiene hacia el comercio exterior:
ambos se llevan peor que los perros y los
gatos.
El proteccionismo en Argentina está tan arraigado
que es uno de los pocos países del mundo
que castiga las exportaciones. Y desde luego,
durante los gobiernos kirchneristas esta filosofía
económica ha encontrado su particular paraíso.
(Cómo podéis ver en pantalla, los diferentes
gobiernos argentinos llevan años tomando
medidas para restringir cada vez más el comercio
internacional y aislar a la Argentina del
resto del mundo. Tan solo durante los primeros
dos años de Macri se produjo una cierta liberalización,
muy suave, casi imperceptible. El resto del
tiempo… Barrera al comercio.: licencias,
trámites, permisos, aranceles y todo tipo
de limitaciones tanto para importar como para
exportar. Argentina se ha convertido en un
sinónimo de alergia a la libre movilidad
de bienes, servicios y capitales.)
Y la pregunta es, ¿pero por qué demonios
el estado argentino es tan estricto con este
tema? ¿De qué les sirva limitar tanto los
flujos comerciales de entrada y salida del
país? ¿No se supone acaso que exportar es
bueno para que la industria y las empresas
argentinas puedan crecer?
Pues el problema, amigos, es que en este país,
el tango de la lógica se baila al ritmo de
la querida, amada y ultra protegida industria
nacional.
“Basta ver como los países más desarrollados
protegen a sus trabajadores a sus industrias
ya sus productores)
Ccon lo cual pasa a ser un importantísimo
actor, el Estado Nacional, en mantener la
competitividad de la industria, mantener la
competitividad de la actividad económica)
Seguirá siendo objetivo de nuestro gobierno
que la industria nacional vuelva a ocupar
un lugar preponderante dentro de la economía
Y es que, veréis, buena parte del ideario
peronista en materia económica se ciñe a
dos principios: el consumo y la producción
nacional. Básicamente, les encantaría vivir
en una especie de autarquía. Puede parecer
extraño en el mundo globalizado en el que
vivimos, pero en Argentina esta es la forma
de pensar de buena parte de la clase política,
si no de la inmensa mayoría.
Y como se dice en el país gaucho, para muestra…
basta un botón. Fijaos.
La idea es que la industria nacional no tenga
que competir con bienes producidos en otras
partes del mundo, lo que supuestamente protege
puestos de trabajo y ese concepto que algunos
denominan… Orgullo de la soberanía económica.
Todo un relato que al final no hace, sino
mantener un modelo de empresas poco competitivas,
falta de oportunidades, retraso tecnológico
y altos costes.
Echemos un vistazo, por ejemplo, a la industria
texto, una de las más protegidas de todo
el aparato productivo de Argentina.
C1 (En lo que respecta a la carga tributaria
por sectores, los mayores impuestos recaen
sobre las importaciones de indumentaria, cuyo
arancel de importación promedio es del 35,0%,
al que hay que sumar el 7,5% de impuesto PAIS
y 3% de Tasa Estadística, para llegar a un
impuesto total del 45,5%. Eugenio Mari, Fundación
LyP, agosto 2023)
¿Y qué supone esto? Pues… Veréis, creo
que por todos es ampliamente conocido el grave
problema que Argentina tiene con la inflación…
De ahí precisamente el plan de dolarización
que tiene Milei y sobre el que hemos publicado
varios vídeos en nuestro canal hermano VisualEconomik.
Si aún no lo conoces, no esperes más. Tenéis
el enlace en la descripción.
El caso es que si miramos de cerca cómo se
comportan los precios de los sectores protegidos,
podemos encontrar una tendencia más que curiosa:
Como podéis ver, mientras que la inflación
crece de forma más o menos coherente, el
precio de la ropa es tremendamente volátil,
como si los flujos comerciales de este producto
cambiaran drásticamente de precios de la
noche a la mañana.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Por qué rayos ocurre
esto? Pues porque el Estado argentino no protege
industrias de buenas a primera, sino que lo
hace a cambio de firmar “acuerdos de precios”
que luego le permite a los políticos justificar
más controles sobre la economía.
C2 (16 de diciembre de 2022: Acuerdo de precios
con el sector de indumentaria. Este entendimiento,
presentado por el ministro de Economía, Sergio
Massa, y el secretario de Comercio, Matías
Tombolini, garantiza la estabilidad de los
precios de más de 50 marcas de indumentaria,
que estarán disponibles en todo el territorio
nacional en locales propios de las firmas.
Gobierno de Argentina)
Es una especie de juego que consiste en algo
así, el gobierno dice: venga, yo te protejo
de las importaciones, pero a cambio acordamos
unos precios y unos márgenes de ganancias.
¿Y sabéis qué? Los picos y los valles del
gráfico responden justamente al vencimiento
y renovación de esos acuerdos.
Al final los argentinos pierden, pero por
e l camino los políticos sacan pecho y los
empresarios cercanos al gobierno evitan la
competencia.
Claro que en ocasiones la dinámica pasa de
ser un romántico relato de soberanía económica,
a una oscura trama de chantaje, porque cuando
la cosa se pone fea, el Estado rápidamente
amenaza con abrir la economía:
N4 (18 de octubre de 2022: Sergio Massa amenazó
con abrir la importación de ropa si no frenan
los aumentos desmesurados de precios. Infobae)
Pero, pese a todo, aunque pueda resultar paradójico,
la libertad de competencia es algo a lo que
muchas empresas argentinas le tienen pavor,
mucho más que al gobierno. Y por supuesto,
no solo hablamos de la industria textil, sino
también del sector automotriz, la industria
electrónica o al del caucho y el plástico,
entre muchas otras.
Y esto es algo que lleva pasando ya desde
hace muchísimo tiempo.
N5 (18 de septiembre de 2008: La Unión Industrial
Argentina (UIA) le pide más protección a
Cristina. Cronista)
N6 (13 de abril de 2009: Nuevo titular de
la Unión Industrial Argentina reclama al
Gobierno más medidas proteccionistas. Iprofesional)
Todo esto es lo que se ha venido a conocer
como empresarios prebendarios, es decir, empresarios
que viven básicamente del gobierno.
Sus empresas no son las más productivas,
no son eficientes, no son innovadores, pero
pese a todo persisten. Muchas veces ni siquiera
se machacan por producir a pleno rendimiento,
¿para qué?
De hecho, los sectores más protegidos de
la industria argentina tienen tasas de uso
de su capacidad industrial menores que las
del promedio del país.
En resumen, el sector productivo argentino
tampoco está preparado para aprovechar la
nueva oleada de jóvenes que está llegando
al mercado laboral.
Y el problema es incluso mayor: pensadlo bien.
Si de repente todo este modelo de proteccionismo
cayera, es muy posible que muchas empresas
argentinas quebrarían. Las transiciones rara
vez son fáciles. Hay que hacerlas, es indispensable,
pero hay que saber que pueden ser duras.h
Dicho esto todavía nos falta por ver un último
elemento clave en toda esta historia.
Atentos.
(¿PUEDEN TODOS PONERSE LA “10”?)
Vale, lo acabamos de ver, en Argentina no
se aprovecha intensamente el capital humano,
ni tampoco existe una matriz empresarial que
sea productiva, innovadora y capaz de competir
en mercados abiertos. [Por supuesto, siempre
hay excepciones]
Pero… Más allá del capital humano y de
las empresas, ¿Qué ocurre con las instituciones?
Pues… desgraciadamente en Argentina reina
un electoralismo feroz, un electoralismo qué
está por encima de cualquier cosa… Incluso
del propio país.
(Sin ir más lejos, la campaña presidencia
de 2023 ha sido una de las polarizadas y acaloradas
de toda la historia argentina. Para Massa,
Milei era una amenaza violenta de extrema
derecha dispuesta a destruir las instituciones
del país, mientras que para Milei, su adversario
condenaría al país a una eterna hambruna
y miseria.
Es el momento de preguntarnos si queremos
seguir transitando este sendero decadente
que hace que cada día seamos más miserables
que tengamos cada vez más pobres que tengamos
más indigentes donde los chicos se tienen
que ir del país para buscar un futuro os
un país condenado)
Entendiendo que hay algunos que ni siquiera
me votan convencido sino simplemente como
vehículo para no elegir un camino que es
violencia que es Odio que es daño)
A 40 años el clima político de la Argentina
no parece el mejor. El nuevo presidente viene
con una agenda bajo el brazo que promete reconstruir
el país de arriba a abajo. La pregunta es,
¿logrará Milei sacarlo adelante y establecer
un nuevo marco narrativo que domine la política
argentina de las próximas décadas?)
Ahora la llegada de Javier Milei a la primera
plana de la política argentina abre la puerta
a una enorme revolución para cambiarlo todo.
De tener un banco central que ahoga el acceso
al dólar e imprime pesos a lo loco, a dolarizar
la economía. De cerrarse al mundo a prometer
echar abajo todas las barreras. De nacionalizar
empresas a privatizarlas.
Es quizás una revolución necesaria… Pero,
¿será capaz de generar un consenso político
más amplio en torno a las reformas?
(“Quiero decirles a todos los argentinos
y a todos los dirigentes políticos que todos
aquellos que quieran sumarse a la Nueva Argentina
serán bienvenidos. No importa de dónde vengan.
No importa que hayan hecho antes. No importa
qué diferencia tengamos, Estoy
seguro que es más importante lo que nos une
que los que nos separa porque eso es
lo que va a hacer que pongamos de pie a la
patria y volvamos a ser una potencia”)
Ojo que esto no es ninguna tontería. Los
países con más éxito económico suelen
compartir una premisa: todas las fuerzas políticas
relevantes han estado comprometidas con los
fundamentos clave del modelo económico. Es
decir, los diferentes gobiernos han mantenido
el rumbo de la nave, solo con ligeras variaciones.
Pero para eso hace falta un claro consenso
político. Si no pronto puede llegar otro
gobierno a la Casa Rosada para darle otro
manotazo al timón. Desde un punto de vista
político, esto es particularmente tentador
si la transición de modelo se hace más dura
de lo previsto.
La pregunta es, ¿lo conseguirá Javier Milei?
Si lo logra, Argentina lo tiene todo para
volver a brillar:
Es un país joven, la extensa región de la
Pampa sigue siendo una tierra muy fértil
y el país tiene un montón de recursos naturales
de todo tipo, incluyendo, petróleo, gas y
litio.
Pero dicho esto, la pregunta es para ti: ¿Crees
que Argentina volverá a despegar? ¿Logrará
Milei labrar un consenso amplio en torno a
las reformas? Déjanos como siempre tus impresiones
en los comentarios y abramos debate.
Y ahora, si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante,
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.